[Applaudissements]
alors est sûre tu as senti alors là tu
as encore comment tu vas à la
aujourd'hui ça va mieux
fatigués mais encore faut-il encore
fatigué je me mets au vide
oui et a eu plusieurs problèmes de santé
dernièrement ce qu'est ce qui s'est
passé mais en fait j'avais déjà eu la
copie de mois de décembre mais j'avais
réussi à lutter avec des dos les bras
d'un petit caux vide
ainsi voilà un petit colis à nos défauts
et on peut on peut en avoir que j'avais
perdu le goût l'odorat et j'ai eu de la
fièvre j'ai perdu 22 kilos quand même au
mois de décembre
je passe de 80 à 60 60 et quelques donc
moi je pensais ne plus la voir
et puis là je suis monté à paris puisque
j'avais des rendez vous d'affaires et
puis pendant une semaine j'étais à 41
degrés de fièvre plus de goût pareil je
suis je fais partie des 2 % qui peuvent
avoir le coc vie de foi donc cette fois
ci j'ai eu mais j'ai eu envie de plus
donc j'ai eu 41 degrés de fièvre pendant
plusieurs jours avec toujours la perte
la perte des kills et du beau-père du
groupe air de tout est très malin j'ai
cru que j'allais mourir mais justement
j'ai failli mourir puisque en fait le
propriétaire venant me cherchais
justement c'était celle de monsieur
jeune homme qu'on a vu là un monsieur se
gâte c'est ça je sais pas voilà donc ce
que tu avais pris à airbnb c'est ça oui
ce monsieur là voilà elle est à
retrouver parce que il nous a raconté
qu'il a retrouvée inanimée
mais comment ça se fait c'est elle ou
quoi parce que j'avais des locaux vides
depuis une semaine je me battais avec
mes souliers prêt n'était pas à ses
forces avec thomas coville ou pas le oui
parce que j'avais je m'en étais rendu
compte à cause de la perte du goût
d'accord et de leur avenir fêter reste
est à part plus de médecins non j'ai pas
appeler le médecin je pensais que ça
allait placer comme un mois de décembre
ouais donc lui qui les appuient les
pompiers ce moment là parce qu'il m'a
retrouvé inanimé à take shelter et est
tombé dans un mini komax et je ne suis
pas tombé dans un mini comme alstom ce
sont mes danse dans un coma ouais
vraiment j'ai vraiment cinq jours de
coma avec un arrêt cardiaque
non donc je suis le lundi je suis arrivé
le lundi
et quand j'ai rouvert les yeux j'étais
vendredi j'avais un appareil qui
arrêtera qatar artificiel donc du coup
je verrai va parler quand tu t'es
réveillé tu t'es vue à l'hôpital tu
étais dans quel état de psychologique
quand on est comme ça quand on a la
pareille dans la bouche déjà on a les
cordes vocales qui semble ok donc on est
à fond on peut rien demander
quand j'ai compris qu'on était vendredi
j'ai ça fait bizarre parce que ça
faisait cinq jours que j'avais aucun
souvenir de rien que ces cinq jours dans
un coma ces cinq jours dans un réel coma
avec un arrêt cardiaque on m'a dit plus
tard dumont le bar dit le lendemain de
mon arrivée j'ai fait un arrêt cardiaque
c'était un miracle que je que je reparte
et ce suite à ça j'ai eu une infection
pulmonaire
un de mes deux poumons étaient infectés
c'est donc un ennemi en aérosol mois les
médecins et on dit que c'était passé
très proche de 2 la mort et ils ont dit
que j'ai été une miraculée c'est pour ça
que je voulais en parler parce que
franchement après la couche plein de ma
fille je mettrais l'aco vide dans la c
était le moment le plus dur le plus
pénible et c'est là où j'ai le plus
souffert je sais que ce soir tu voulais
venir témoigner c'est les lois n'a aussi
que vous venez témoigner pour tous les
gens qui prennent pas aussi en
considération les gestes barrières les
qui disent oui dans salariés sont jaugés
souffert le franchement le plus de
dommages
je me suis vu mourir je vais mourir
vraiment tu te dis je me suis vu mourir
mais même par rapport à ça près quand je
me suis réveillé du combat il m'a fallu
inclinés pour leur apprendre à marcher
parce que je perdais l'equilibre jeu
donc que j'ai eus incliné pendant trois
jours j'ai eu une diététicienne simard
est incorporé de liquide
donc on passe la purée au yaourt et
après on passe au solide pendant cinq
jours donc ne prenez pas c'est à la
légère parce que réellement vouloir
mourir mais déjà vous souffre énormément
puisque il ya les crampes comme comme
une grippe x 10 et ensuite il faut
réapprendre à marcher et réapprendre à
allonger et géré perdu ses kilos sur
cette facile mais le corps est fatigué
très fatigué donc faut vraiment pas le
prendre à la légère et je sais pas
comment je vais attraper mais j'ai 44
ans j'en ai pas 70 et comme quoi ça peut
arriver à tout le monde
aujourd'hui
tahar fait tous les examens au niveau de
tes poumons c'était reste que ça va
mieux que ce que tu étais sorti
d'affaires tout est bon de tout et les
poumons les aérosols ils ont réussi à me
guérir et puis l aco vis de moi c'est
bon je m'en suis sorti quand on sort du
coma après ils n'auraient apprennent à
marcher ailleurs nous apprennent à
manger
après on s'en sort mais il reste quand
même une grosse fatigue et de par le
coma ce soit on court très fatigué je
fait il très vite quand je monte les
marches ou quand j'ai fait des longues
distances
tu viens aujourd'hui loana pour
l'instant je vis à cheryl aleri l'état
bob weir cyril je suis descendu au
lavandou d'accord me reposer au bord de
la mer étuver cheryl inouïe comment tous
quand tu t'es vu partir c'est encore une
nouvelle épreuve pour toi c'est vrai que
c'est incroyable ce que tu vis à chaque
fois c'est à chaque fois tu te on se dit
à chaque fois
luan arrive à se relever et c'est ça qui
nous fait plaisir mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient dans quel
état est ce que tu es dans un état de ce
que tu es conquérant pas ce que tu dis
je suis passé à côté de la mort vraiment
j'ai envie de me battre aujourd'hui
au contraire j'ai le moral à fond parce
que j'ai vécu le pire et j'ai envie
d'aller de l'avant
c'est exactement ça le jeu conquérante
maintenant j'ai envie de faire plein de
choses j'ai plein de projets j'ai soif
de la ville est en fête cesco vide se
vide lourd que tu as eue
repeat a fait comprendre conscience de
beaucoup de choses oui parce que je
je me prenais trop en pitié je passais
trop au passé
et je ne prenais pas je faisais pas
attention au futur et au présent et
cette chance qui m'est donnée quand je
me suis réveillé quand on m'a raconté
tout ce qui m'était arrivé maintenant
j'ai plein de projets pour l'avenir et
je suis plus conquérante j'ai envie
d'aller mieux j'ai envie de faire du
sport
j'ai envie de m'inscrire que je remets
de revenir seul que j'étais enfin je
sache forte que je j'ai bien bah oui
j'ai bien commencé
oui sinon c'est vrai